in this video we will talk about the
neuron a neuron is an electrically
excitable cell that processes and
transmits information through both the
electrical and chemical signals let's
first talk about the structure of the
neuron as you can see the majority of
the neurons are made up of three main
parts the first main part is the
dendrites of the neuron the second main
part of the neuron is the cell body and
the third wind part of the neuron is the
axon let's first talk about the
dendrites and dendrites
they usually arise from the cell body
and they are variable in number the
dendrites basically get thinner with
every branching of the nendroid
now talking about the cell body of the
neuron the cell body basically consists
of all these typical cell organelle is
like the mitochondria and a plasmic
reticulum nucleus cytosol etc one
special type of
organelle that is present in the cell
body of the neuron are these missiles
granules which are basically the
collection of endoplasmic reticulum
these are the rough endoplasmic
reticulum and the help in the protein
synthesis of the neuron now talking
about the axon of the neuron the axon is
usually a single structure which arises
from the cell body of the neuron and the
axon basically usually remains a
constant diameter throughout its length
and the point of origin of the axon from
the cell body is known as the axon
hillock the axon in majority of the
neurons is covered by a myelin sheath
which helps in electrical insulation and
proper electrical conduction of the axon
and the structure you see here are the
axon terminal of the axon and these are
basically a collection of synaptic bulbs
which are connected to the dendrites of
the further axons and these axon
terminals release chemical transmitters
most commonly the GABA and the glutamate
which helped in generating new impulses
in the neurons which are connected to
these synaptic bulbs so this was a brief
description about the structure of the
neuron let's talk about how the signal
is transmitted across a neuron so
talking about the neuron signal
transmission as you can see in this
diagram we have three neurons the neuron
member - and the neuron number three are
connected to the synaptic terminals of
the axon number one so to begin the
neuron signal transmission one important
term I would like you to mention is the
resting potential which is the
electrical potential in the neurons at
their resting state and it is minus 70
millivolts so the initiating event in
the neuron signal transmission is
usually firing of the synaptic terminals
which are connected to the dendrites of
the axon number one and when the action
potential develops inside the axon
number one it causes the depolarization
of the axon number one across its whole
length and this electrical signal
transmits across the whole length of the
axon number one and when this positive
signal reaches the synaptic terminal of
the axon one it causes the release of
neurotransmitters and these
neurotransmitters interact with the
dendrites of the axon number one - and
the axon number three and the cause
development of similar action potentials
in both the axons which are connected to
the axon number one so this is how the
electrical signal transmits across the
various axons thank you so much for
watching this video I hope you find this
video helpful don't forget to hit the
like button below and also make sure to
subscribe to our Channel also don't
forget to Like us on Facebook for latest
updates about the videos